Buonasera buonasera benvenute avete una
prenotazione no allora purtroppo con le
ciabatte non si può accedere al locale
volendo visto che la lista d'attesa è
veramente molto lunga sia all'incirca
due ore due ore e mezza potrebbe tornare
a casa a cambiarsi e tornare qui il
vostro nome vecchia rotti avete qualche
allergia qualche intolleranza è
un'occasione speciale non credo casa
volete stare fuori no fuori proprio
impossibile Sì sì siamo in overbooking
da 3 settimane il tavolo che
eventualmente mi si starebbe liberando e
è quello lì No No quello lì proprio
quello quello davanti alla cucina sì ah
no no non passa quasi mai nessuno
e i tavoli che vede vuoti e si sono
prenotati la devo solo avvisare che sono
le 11:30 e a mezzanotte Chiudi la cucina